well that's one of those questions that
you can't answer I mean yeah we're
probably post post-modernism but what
was supposed modernism such that were
post of its oh it's pretty tricky but i
think that the period in the 50s and 60s
was a period of kind of high veneration
of the modernists like Elliott and
comparable figures in the world of art
and so on and that the 60s and the 70s
kind of replaced that with a different
cannon so when I started out as actually
a Victorian asst that was my field I did
19th century British literature but by
some fluke of the job market I got a job
teaching modern literature ended up
writing a book on TSLA who was in those
days sort of king of of a modern
literary form and criticism as well but
now the cannons very different from that
period people don't write about Elliott
impound anymore so that's really changed
a lot and I think our sensibility is not
modernist anymore that is sensibility of
people who are interested in in art and
literature
I wouldn't say that I mean it's the
clients a funny word to use about any
cultural moment I think things are
different from the way they were 40 or
50 years ago but the media are different
interests are different you know the
demographics are different it's just a
different world just in higher education
alone more people go to college now by
enormous amounts then went to college in
the 50s and 60s so that represents a
whole new literate public that's a
consumer of literature of news of print
of you know opinion and that that's a
bigger audience and a much more diverse
audience than it used to be so it's
really hard to talk about decline i
think it's just things do shift and then
when things shift one's own role in the
culture shifts along with it and you
have to adjust it